un mythe attendant illégale nous pensons
à toi ils seront libres que quand il le
fera les images qui ont été réalisées
par un artiste motivé concerné aussi qui
de son côté dans ses concerts aussi
prend à partie le public pour les
appeler à leur soutien c'est romane
serda qui érigeait ces images ma petite
femme que j'aime et que j'en passe
j'allais suivre une chanson pouvait
faire bouger des choses comme ça je sais
pas à quel point la difficulté de la
famille bettencourt des gens des comités
de soutien en facilité ou non d'avoir
accès aux médias n'est pas de micros
tendus
c'était une chanson porté par un
chanteur connu arrive sur ce sujet pour
que des demandes d'interviews de caméras
du monde entier trois jours après la
première diffusion de cette chanson chez
votre meilleur ami fogiel la semaine
dernière j'ai une demande d'interview
d'une radio en direct direct de bogota
et j'ai pu adresser au peuple colombien
aux otages convient peut-être espérons
et à une grid bien sûr et à clara rojas
son ami un message de solidarité des
citoyens du monde à travers cette
interview j'espère qu'il y en aura
d'autres
voilà j'espère que la version espagnole
touchera toute l'amérique du sud et la
version anglaise
le reste de la planète et la version
française forcément la suisse la
belgique la francophonie quoi français
les québec je pense que les chansons de
johnny clegg ont plus se fait pour la
libération de mandela et pour la fin de
l'apartheid que tout les résidents les
résolutions de l'onu
et voilà c'était un petit coup de
chapeau au passage a donné qu'il faut
combattre
évidemment ces sciences chez nous qui
était otage en irak avec bruno a dit le
pire pour un otage
c'est de se sentir oubliés donc la grâce
à vous et grâce à tout ce qui est fait
on espère qu ingrid ne se sentira pas
complètement oublié mais met la pression
sur le gouvernement français en lui
demandant de se mobiliser
est ce que si une bonne stratégie est ce
que ça risque pas de braquer le
président horribles contre nous ou l'une
à la la cour suprême en colombie a
accepté que au lieu le président que
l'on actuels puissent se représenter aux
prochaines élections qui ont lieu en
colombie en mai 2006 il a changé la
constitution pour ça vous comprendre que
il a complètement un double langage
quand il a été élu il ya bientôt quatre
ans une des premières choses qu'il a
fait c'est aller chez ma grand mère et
lui dire je ferai tout pour que ingrid
et les otages reviennent mais depuis il
ne fait que stopper toutes les
initiatives tous les moments où on
pensait qu enfin on allait aboutir à
quelque chose que vous d'être un
dialogue allait s'ouvrir à chaque moment
il a tout fait pour pour empêcher que
quelque chose se produise donc
donc il faut comprendre que il faut
mettre de la pression sur le
gouvernement que l'on dit ici et
maintenant que les élections qui les
apprentis approche c'est un moment très
important qu'on ait une fenêtre qui
s'ouvre
on a jusqu'à mai 2010 donne je suis
maintenant voilà c'est quand j'ai
entendu parler comme ça et par emi ou de
à la télévision que j'étais bouleversée
par son courage et son mais vous êtes
très courageux aussi renault pour qu'un
courage si je vous prie monsieur faire
fogiel et ardisson à deux semaines
d'intervalle ça oui
pour un jeu voyons les farc les forces
armées révolutionnaires colombiennes la
branche armée du parti communiste
colombiens y luttent contre la pauvreté
oui illustre contre la corruption etc
des choses que vous défendrez volumes
additionnels de poser ses questions oui
idéologiquement ce soutien à leur combat
contre l'oppression entre la misère
contre l'ignorance contre la
malnutrition d'entre le manque
d'éducation le manque de liberté dans
leur pays comme je soutiens toutes les
libérations des peuples et lutte armée
c'est paradoxal c'est leur méthode pour
lutter pour leur idée utiliser le
kidnapping de masse trois mines 4200
otage aujourd'hui en colombie il ya les
chiffres
trente mille morts par an les exactions
quand ils arrivent dans les villages
qu'ils ont obligés à enrôler les paysans
de force en leur promettant 3 dollars
par jour ce qui nourrit toute une
famille de paysans et quand ils
trafiquent la drogue sont richissimes
les dirigeants des farc parce qu'ils
sont et s'ils font partie des cartels de
distribution de la drogue dans le monde
entier je dénonce totalement ces
méthodes qui discrédite leurs combats
futiles beau à l'origine au départ
c'est la vie
sans viser
avec ses portes